Спеціалізована антикорупційна прокуратура
мала стати важливою ланкою
у боротьбі з корупцією в Україні
Що їй вдалося за майже три роки роботи, а що ні?
САП з’явилася в Україні восени 2015-го
За цей час спільно з НАБУ
було відкрито 500 проваджень
і близько 140 направлені до суду
Проте за майже три роки діяльності антикорупційної прокуратури дива не сталося
топ-корупціонери за ґратами так і не опинилися
Ба більше - відомство Назара Холодницького
закрило чимало резонансних справ
Серед останніх - так звана
справа про "рюкзаки Авакова"
одним із фігурантів якої був син очільника
МВС України - Олександр Аваков
САП несподівано закрила провадження,
пояснюючи це тим
що провину на себе взяв представник фірми-переможця тендера
на поставку рюкзаків для Нацгвардії
З-поміж ключових справ, які "зависли"
оглядачі називають
також і провадження щодо хабаря
голові Центрвиборчкому Михайлу Охендовському
з "чорної каси" Партії регіонів
Антикорупційна прокуратура тимчасово призупинила розслідування
і шансів на його відновлення, як констатують експерти, дуже мало
Крім того, серед провалених згадується
і так звана справа Супрун
Рік тому виконувачка обов’язків міністра охорони здоров’я
звернулася до НАБУ через те, що їй пропонували
хабар у вигляді квартири
Серед підозрюваних був мер Вишневого Ілля Діков
Попри відеодокази надання хабаря,
САП підозру не оголосила
Замість цього Холодницький повернув
справу на доопрацювання
і змінив прокурорів, які над нею працювали
Не знайшла САП і доказів проти колишнього міністра екології
та природних ресурсів за часів Януковича -
Миколи Злочевського
Торік у серпні прокурори закрили справу щодо видачі ліцензій
на користування надрами
фірмам екс-урядовця
через те, що начебто
не було доведено факт злочину
Натомість сам Злочевський, за даними ЗМІ
безперешкодно повернувся до України
Серед найбільших досягнень САП експерти називають
скеровану до суду так звану газову справу
в якій фігурує нардеп-утікач Олександр Онищенко
Слідство оцінює збитки українській державі
нанесені його діями в межах цієї справи, у близько трьох мільярдів гривень
І ще одна успішна операція, за оцінками оглядачів
так звана "бурштинова справа" народного депутата Борислава Розенблата
Нині сторона захисту знайомиться з матеріалами
і теоретично справа може бути скерована до суду
вже найближчим часом
Втім, експерти не виключають, що в останній момент прокурори можуть передумати
і це провадження повторить долю
справи "рюкзаків Авакова"
Разом із тим, передача справи до суду
ще не означає
що вона не пилитиметься там, а буде доведена до логічного завершення
Адже попри чималу кількість скерованих антикорупційною прокуратурою
до Феміди проваджень
жодного вироку досі немає